Another day, another failed attempt at death.
If SCP-682 had anything even resembling a
sense of humor, he might ask for it to be
printed on a motivational poster and stuck
to the side of his containment chamber, where
he eternally melts and regrows at the mercy
of high-concentration acid.
They’d just cross-tested him with Able.
Again.
Unlike some of the others he’d been forced
to face, that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn’t intelligent enough to fear.
He’d always come back, just as stupid and
violent.
This encounter had left the Hard to Destroy
Reptile at thirty percent of his previous
body mass, bloody and bashed.
He’d survived the encounter.
He always survived.
They brought what was left of him back to
his cell in a forklift.
A blasted forklift!
How could it even be more humiliating?
As his eyes started to grow back in his head,
he could swear he even saw one of the technicians
laughing at him.
His name tag read, “Agent Nigel Kelly.”
Noted. 682 would specifically hunt down and
kill him the next time he breached.
Of course, every single day, he plotted revenge
against the human race - along with everything
else.
But the sum they owed in pain, blood, and
despair could never be repaid in full.
After all, every single one of them
- except Dr. Bright -
could only really die once.
They’d brought 682 to the precipice a thousand
times, only for his own body to cheat him,
and deprive him of the sweet release of death.
And if the Foundation had their way, it would
be done a thousand times more, and they wouldn’t
even stop there.
682 couldn’t even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to deal
a blow even comparable to the one he had faced.
All he could do was dream.
Dream of a reckoning that would turn the tables.
Something that would plunge humanity into
the state of constant pain and terror that
had been all he’d ever known since these
fumbling sadists in white coats had locked
him up here.
What a beautiful day that would be...
Little did SCP-682 know, that very day was
about to break.
Miles and miles away from the facility where
SCP-682 was kept - after all, orders from
the O5 Council have hard mandates on the minimum
distances between people and a site holding
a monster as volatile as 682 - parents watched
their children laughing and frolicking in
an idyllic playground.
Some squealed with glee as they descended
the slide.
Some of the more ambitious little tykes tried
to go over the bar on the swings.
Others waited in line for some delicious soft
serve at a parked Ice Cream truck.
One mother bought an ice cream cone and walked
over to a nearby bench, where she began to
enjoy her delicious frozen treat.
It was a remarkably hot day out and a little
ice cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied.
You could see the distant air wobbling in
the heat.
Already, her ice cream was starting to melt,
white rivulets dribbling down the sides of
the cone and onto her hands.
Suddenly, almost imperceptibly, the quality
of the light shifted.
The kind of thing you’d dismiss as a trick
of the eyes and forget just as quickly, were
it not for the catastrophic effects that were
about to unfold.
As the woman leaned forward to lick her melting
ice cream, something dripped onto her skirt.
But, as she looked down, she slowly realized
that what dripped onto her wasn’t the pure
white of her ice cream: It was the exact same
tone as her skin.
She felt a terrible burning sensation all
through her body.
The most horrible, debilitating pain she’d
ever experienced, like every cell in her body
was screaming and trying to make a break for
it.
She turned to the other parents sitting near
the playground.
They were screaming too.
Each collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness, different parts of their body falling
at different speeds as they transitioned through
states of matter.
When they hit the ground, they were taking
on a liquid state.
Screaming, worthless, boneless blobs.
The woman even saw her own arm wilting like
a time lapse video of a dying flower.
She dripped and sluiced through the cracks
in the bench, until nothing recognizably human
was left.
Only a soggy ice cream cone sitting uneaten.
In an instant, billions of screams rang out
over planet earth.
Day had broken.
Things would never, ever be the same again,
as almost half of humanity instantaneously
took on a liquid state.
Needless to say, with the most dangerous and
far-reaching anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind of
warning, the SCP Foundation was incredibly
busy.
This would take some unprecedented action.
The members of the O5 Council who weren’t
melted during the initial blast convened over
secure video link while sequestering themselves
underground.
In what amounted to multiple human lifetimes
of some of the most high-pressure choices
imaginable, they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the SCP Foundation.
In the service of all mankind, they would
now break the masquerade.
The SCP Foundation would, at long last, step
out of the shadows to save the rest of humanity
from the tyranny of the light.
Broadcasts went out all over the globe.
Every TV screen, every livestream, every radio
broadcast was commandeered.
They gave instructions based on the scattered
intel they had.
For some reason, the sun had turned against
them.
Exposure would lead to any biological creatures
melting away into sentient piles of flesh-colored
sludge.
People would remain indoors and away from
any light sources.
All windows must remain covered.
Travel only at night, and even then, heavily
covered with protective gear.
There can only be one objective for whoever
is left: Make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek refuge
inside.
If anyone could figure out the answer to this
terrifying existential riddle, it would be
the SCP Foundation.
Anyone who was exposed should be considered
lost.
While, as always, the SCP Foundation did all
they could to project a sense of control over
the situation, on the inside, it was pandemonium.
Somehow, despite everything, this event had
taken all of them by surprise.
How could anyone have predicted that the cradle
of our solar system’s delicate living balance
would suddenly become a meat grinder?
A huge number of Foundation operatives were
wiped out in the initial exposure.
Global communication infrastructure had been
devastated.
It was pure chaos.
And to SCP-682, as another evil tactician
once put it, chaos was a ladder.
From the inside of his acid tank, 682 could
sense the fear and pain suddenly exuding from
his surrounding environment.
It was greater than ever before.
What was happening out there?
This was no average containment breach.
Something was really, really happening out
there.
682 began to adapt and finely attune its hearing,
until it could pick up chatter from outside.
“Maybe we can convert some of the D-Class
barracks into serviceable bunkers for the
refugees?
It’s not like we’re prepared for this
kind of capacity!”
“Oh god, oh god, we’ve lost Site 7, Site
10, Site 23, Site 40, Site 52...”
“Death toll looks to be in the billions.
Well, we don’t know if they’re dead, technically.
But they’re sure as hell not human anymore...”
“This is the Big One.
This is it.
XK-Class.
Even 2000 is unaccounted for.
Is O5 crazy that they think we fight the freaking
sun!?”
Needless to say, 682’s curiosity was piqued.
Anything that could light a fire under the
Foundation like this was something he could
enjoy.
And, with his impressively strategic intellect,
he intuited that a time of great strife for
the Foundation would be the perfect time to
breach containment.
Cause whenever there’s violence, fear, and
chaos on a mass scale, SCP-682 will be there,
causing it.
682 began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful alkaline
substance.
Little by little, the alkaline neutralized
the acid surrounding him, turning it into
little more than plain water.
He then converted his internal systems to
have extreme endothermic rather than exothermic
properties, causing his surrounding temperature
to drop rapidly, until all the water in the
tank completely froze around him.
The ice expanded beyond the limit of the containment
unit, busting the rivets of the metal frame
and shattering the reinforced glass.
With this goal achieved, 682 raised his internal
temperatures to incredible highs, melting
the ice around him.
Once again, he was free, and ready for some
good, old-fashioned carnage and mayhem.
Perhaps he could get a better handle on this
strange new situation, too.
It was all rather exciting.
Just a girl with goals huh?
SCP Foundation personnel were already running
around like ants trying desperately to avoid
the caustic laser beam of the magnifying glass.
You can only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through the
wall, Kool-Aid man style, and began to ruthlessly
massacre everyone around him.
Just one of those days, you know?
The typical order during a 682 containment
breach is to dispatch all available units
to get him back under control.
The issue with this particular containment
breach was that, given the human population
was very rapidly being melted and they were
the only ones who could potentially save the
rest, they didn’t really have any available
units to pursue and recontain 682.
For once, he really wasn’t a priority, and
that meant terrible things for whoever he
ran into.
682 slaughtered his way through any researchers
or guards who dared to get in his way.
Disgusting creatures, really.
Better off dead.
He clawed and bit and tore and crushed with
almost childlike glee, leaving great piles
of bodies in his wake.
All the while, he was pondering the things
he heard those Foundation drones saying.
Something about the sun and an XK-Class scenario.
Interesting. 682 also observed that any apertures
that could potentially allow light into the
facility had also been shuttered.
Perhaps they weren’t overreacting this time,
like they always did with him.
Maybe they were dealing with some kind of
phenomenon that would now cast this wretched
world and those who lived in it into the void.
Wouldn’t that be a fitting karmic fate for
them all.
Still, 682’s bloodlust didn’t outweigh
his logic.
He needed to know more about this situation
before proceeding.
And in this, maybe he could kill two Foundation
birds with one stone...
Elsewhere in the building, alarms blared,
the air was suffused with panicked voices
and frequent screams.
Nobody knew what was going on, not really.
They’d only gotten details here and there,
and the details they’d received were terrifying.
All their families and loved ones outside...
Probably gone.
So many of the people and so much of the world
they’d been fighting for, risking it all
for, had disappeared in an instant.
Carried to hell on a ray of sunshine.
Why were they still here?
Was this horror not truly uncontainable?
These questions were swimming through the
mind of Agent Nigel Kelly as he stood alone
in his office, almost catatonic.
He’d had friends and family on the outside,
all likely reduced to those horrible fleshy
blobs.
He was alone in the world.
Risking his life for nothing.
How could this get any worse?
His mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again.
And the universe gave him an answer, in the
form of a deep, reptilian voice saying, “Found
you...” into his ear from behind.
He turned with a shriek to see the terrible
eyes of SCP-682 staring into his own.
Before he could try to flee or reach for a
weapon that he knew would only mildly annoy
the already furious beast, 682 reached out
with a massive, clawed hand and grabbed him
by the torso, lifting him up into the air.
The creature was gripping so tight he could
feel his ribs starting to crack.
“You laughed at me, Agent Kelly,” the
monster hissed.
“Am I funny to you?
Do I seem like the type to tell jokes?
Do you feel like laughing now?”
Agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his life,
fighting for his next breath from the crushing
squeeze of the creature’s terrible hand.
682 roared at him to be silent and ordered
him to tell him everything he knew about the
situation going on outside.
If the information was useful, 682 might show
his thought-to-be-non-existent magnanimous
side, and let Agent Kelly live.
Of course, Agent Kelly didn’t fancy his
chances, but what other choice did he have?
He told 682 that the higher-ups were calling
this SCP-001: When Day Breaks.
The sun had gone rogue somehow, and being
in contact with any kind of sunlight would
now cause people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying, living sludge.
And it wasn’t just people.
The condition also affected anomalies, and
interestingly, it appeared to negate all previous
anomalous effects - so 682’s adaptational
ability may not even save it if it was exposed.
He’d told 682 everything he knew.
“Are you going to let me live?”
Agent Kelly asked, struggling to breathe.
682’s terrible maw twisted into what might
have been a smile.
“Oh, Agent Kelly,” he said, with unsettling
joy.
“That was just a joke.
Didn’t you find that one funny?”
A terrible scream emanated from the Agent’s
office.
If one good thing could be said for what happened
to Agent Kelly that day, at least he didn’t
live long enough to see the ravages of the
terrible sun first hand.
682 began to formulate a plan.
He took Agent Kelly’s wristwatch and integrated
it into his body, so he’d have a permanent
internal clock.
It was the middle of summer, so the sun would
have reliably set at 9 PM and would likely
begin its rise at around 5 AM.
It would be relatively easy to avoid the sun,
all things considered.
For lack of a more eloquent way to put it,
when it comes to adapting to new threats,
SCP-682 is simply built different.
After slaughtering a few other members of
SCP Foundation staff for the road - Hey, it’s
not like anyone was fit to stop him - 682
began enacting the next phase of his plan.
His body grew a thick, smooth carapace, and
his front set of limbs began to grow, his
muscles bulging and his claws growing, the
tips turning into sharp, flat scoops.
With sudden and tremendous force, 682 began
boring his way into the ground.
Tunneling, clawing through concrete and dirt
with absolute ease.
Normally, the SCP Foundation would have deployed
high-tech seismic sensors and the kind of
tunnel-boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture him.
But during the endless horrors of the breaking
day, he had carte blanche to escape and live
it up in the ruins of this rapidly dying world.
Eventually, 682 had bored his way into a roomy
sewer pipe, the perfect place to wait out
a few hours.
Up above, so many millions screamed, either
in fear or in agony.
There had been some new developments that
the SCP Foundation had been yet to account
for.
While they knew that those melted by the rogue
sun were technically alive and trapped in
a permanent state of suffering, what the Foundation
didn’t know was that these former humans
were incredibly dangerous in their own right.
The sun hadn’t just irreparably warped their
bodies, it had also irreparably warped their
minds.
It has enslaved them.
Made them zealots.
Acolytes.
They developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant, fleshy masses, driven by the single-minded
purpose of finding victims and dragging them
out into the light, where they too could be
converted into these terrible fleshy creatures
and add to the masses.
They were the rogue sun’s boots on the ground,
metaphorically speaking.
And now, they were the Foundation’s greatest
challenge in getting a handle on this situation
again.
Before, it was just encouraging people to
avoid the sun.
Now, the sun was actively trying to increase
its exposure.
But 682, who was having a relaxing evening
not being melted for once down in the sewers,
couldn’t care less.
He was having the most calming few hours he’d
had in years.
He waited, checking the time, making sure
that it would be dark before he began tunneling
back up to the surface world.
He surfaced in the middle of a city, miles
away from the Foundation facility he’d spend
so many decades being tortured in.
He tasted the cool night air and observed
the desolation that had been wrought all around
him.
Buildings were on fire.
Cars were crashed and overturned.
The ground was cracked.
Garbled SCP Foundation Public Service Announcements
played to nobody in the broken display windows
of electronic stores.
Giant wads of human flesh roamed, slithering
around, searching for new victims.
One noticed 682 and began to approach him,
gibbering madly in a chorus of strange voices.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile wasted no time
in attacking.
It tore apart most of the hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks.
The form may have been different, but it still
tasted like human flesh, and SCP-682 savored
every single bite.
It would be so simple.
These blobs of idiotic flesh were so easy
to kill, and there would be so many terrified
humans in this devastated world, hiding away
in dark places, holding out the hope that
maybe they could reach the safety of a Foundation
facility.
682 chuckled at the very thought.
Foolish hope would drown in an endless well
of black, caustic despair.
He would find them.
He would rest underground in the day and then
hunt them in the dark.
They would all die screaming, bloodying his
claws and fangs.
Nothing and nobody would stop him.
He looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little louder.
It was just...
Delightful.
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“SCP-682 - Craziest Mutations and Adaptations”
for more exploits from the lizard who just
won’t die!